[Musique]
nous sommes le 14 septembre 2016 merci
de nous rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro
voici les invités du jour didier
guillemot tout d'abord président de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reviendra sur
le classement de shanghai qui place son
établissement parmi les 500 meilleurs au
monde elle nous verrons aussi les enjeux
de cette rentrée et puis il nous dira si
lui aussi est favorable à la mise en
place d'une sélection à l'entrée du
masters et puis maylis fleurier
responsable du service des nouveaux
usages des mobilités à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous
présentera le programme de la semaine de
la mobilité une semaine qui valorise les
transports en commun les circulations
douces des animations sont prévues
également au coeur des entreprises
bonsoir à vous deux est bienvenue donc
en plateau malisse fleuret la semaine de
la mobilité va débuter demain jeudi 15
septembre le mot d'ordre de cette
opération qui revient chaque année
est-ce que c'est toujours de valoriser
les transports en commun les
circulations douces c2c une semaine
européenne en fait sur la mobilité et
l'objectif c'est promouvoir toutes les
alternatives au tout voiture donc tous
les modes de transport alternatifs tout
ce qui a été ratifiée avec des
opérations au sein des entreprises aussi
au sein des entreprises et auprès du
grand public avec des jeux sur le réseau
de bus on va détailler tout ça dans un
instant on va regarder plus en détail le
programme mais auparavant didier
guillemot je me tourne vers vous puisque
l'université de versailles saint quentin
a retrouvé sa place parmi le classement
de shanghai la dernière fois c'était en
2011 la première fois c'était en 2011
c'est entre la 400e et la 500e place
c'est ça à peu près que vous se situe
votre établissement au niveau
international absolument c'est c'est
même probablement plus près de là 430e
c'est à dire plus la 400e que de la 60e
et c'est vraiment très très bonne
nouvelle c'est quoi ce classement
concrètement alors c'est le classement
de shanghai c'est un déclassement de
référence pour classer les universités
du monde je crois qu'il ya dix sept
mille universités dans le monde quelque
chose comme ça il se trouve que il ya ce
classement qui est organisé par
l'université de shanghai et qui les
classe principalement sur la visibilité
et la notoriété scientifique
et donc le classement de shanghai s'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga c'est simplement
un classement sur une échelle et bon
voila quand je suis arrivé aux
responsabilités j'ai demandé à ce qu'on
réponde de façon le plus professionnel
possible et le 15 août les résultats
sont dévoyées retrouver ce placement
puisque l'université l'avait quittée un
temps oui je je je voulais retrouver
serre que je voulais savoir où on en
était c'est à dire que je voulais faire
un bilan comme je souhaite faire un
bilan financier un bilan des activités
de notre université et ça fait partie du
bilan et je me disais que si on était
499e c'était mieux que si nous étions
501e et il se trouve que le classement
est plutôt extrêmement bons et que nous
sommes revenus comme vous l'avez dit au
classement de shanghai c'est à dire en
gros parmi les 22 premières universités
françaises sur la dimension classement
de shanghai un mot concernant
l'actualité également fils qu'il ya des
discussions qui occupent les présidents
d'université les syndicats étudiants le
gouvernement également c'est la
sélection en master najat vallaud
belkacem a annoncé au début de la
semaine à sa volonté de régler la
question de la sélection par une loi
élaboré un d'ici au mois d'octobre vous
vous demandez une sélection pour être
clair pour l'entrée en master je pense
qu'il y à deux dimensions dans dans les
universités d'abord nous avons une
mission de service public je pense
qu'atteindre très gros enjeu à permettre
l'accueil et l'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur de la grande majorité de nos
étudiants et nos jeunes ça c'est un
enjeu très important mais la deuxième
chose c'est que effectivement nous avons
besoin aussi parce que nous avons des
cursus qui sont qui demande voilà du
travail et qui peuvent être des moteurs
de notoriété de nos universités et donc
nous avons besoin de la sélection de
temps en temps pour certains diplômes et
moi je ne suis absolument pas
défavorables par contre le point qui me
paraît essentiel c'est
de ne pas sélectionner entre le même
mandat le m2 votre conviction
personnelle et 6,6 élections il doit y
avoir et bien en main et de temps en
temps s'il ya des diplômes cdd avec
sélection il est vraiment bien que la
ministre sont pas de sujet et fasse
avancer la question de la loi faut que
ce soit les prix y ait une loi qui
sortent donc justement les choses soient
soient claires on aura l'occasion
forcément de les dire parler dans les
prochains mois on en revient plus
spécifiquement à cette université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
avec cette question que j'aurais
peut-être pu vous posez en introduction
comment se passe cette première rentrée
pour vous puisque c'est votre première
rentrée en tant que président de
l'université pour moi ou pour nous
étudier j'apporte se passe très bien
pour ce qui concerne nos étudiants et
nos enseignants elle se passe à peu près
comme d'habitude
plutôt pas si mal quelques petits tracas
informatique par exemple pour les
inscriptions n'est rien rien
d'extraordinaire je pense qu'il ya un
point où il ya deux points sur lesquels
il faut peut-être mettre l'emphase
d'abord nous avons renforcé vigipirate
avec une fouille à l'entrée des
bâtiments alors c'est évidemment de
nature à générer un peu de désagrément
des files d'attentes je m'en excuse
évidemment auprès de nos études
d'application et 50 aces mais c'est une
obligation et les enjeux sont quand même
particulièrement important il ya de
l'inquiétude donc voilà j'ai pris la
décision de le faire et puis la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il ya quand même quelque
chose de très nouveau dans notre
diversité j'y suis pas pour grand chose
puisque je le projet a été lancé depuis
longtemps mais c'était la maison de
l'étudiant et il se trouve que le
guichet unique qui se trouve sur le
campus ici il ya de guichet unique un
ici sur campus de l'ufr des sciences
voilà et sur la maison de l'étudiant les
choses fonctionnent très bien
visiblement l'accueil
du guichet unique est extrêmement
apprécié permettant de faire les
inscriptions les mutuelles les cartes de
séjour pour les étudiants notamment
besoin l'inscription aux activités et
tout ça fonctionne très bien j'en suis
absolument ravi de parler des étudiants
étrangers ils sont nombreux justement en
cette rentrée il y en a quelques-uns où
est-ce qu'ils ont déserté l'université
de par des inquiétudes peut-être de
venir en france par exemple non il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas de désertion
d'étudiants étrangers il ya des
étudiants étrangers l'université se doit
être généreuse et d'accueillir les
étudiants étrangers qu'ils viennent et
qui frappent à la porte votre priorité
pour cette année c'est devrait encore
plus son rapprochement avec l'ensemble
entité paris saclay l'université paris-x
sacré oui
paris saclay oui le projet paris-saclay
va avec des rythmes parfois accéléré
parfois un peu ralenti
l'ambition du dsq c'est d'oeuvrer pour
que et de tout faire
malgré les difficultés parfois qui
peuvent survenir pour que le projet
salariés de paris-saclay avance et
avance résolument et pour que nous
répondions est que nous arrivions à
obtenir la pérennisation de ce qu'on
appelle l'idex l'institut d'excellence
les choses n'ont pas forcément si simple
que ça mais sachez que l'université fera
tout pour que ça se concrétise
on va parler de mobilité la présence est
un sujet qui peut aussi vous intéressé
par ce que vos étudiants et les
enseignants se déplace justement malice
furet pour l'agglomération de saint
quentin en quoi cet important de
s'occuper de la mobilité pour une
agglomération dans la mobilité c'est
c'est le quotidien en fait des usagers
c'est comment je me rends à mon travail
comment je vais à mes loisirs comment je
fais mes activités avec l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir le moins
d'impact possible sur l'environnement et
donc d'où l'intérêt pour soutenir les
solutions qui permettent de prendre un
peu moins la voiture donc c'est un outil
qui se met en place il ya un plan de
déplacement inter entreprises par
exemple aussi qu'ils existent ah oui le
plan de déplacement est entrepris c'est
un travail tout au long de l'année pour
avec les entreprises pour faire en sorte
que les gens viennent mieux dans les
entreprises avec d'autres solutions que
la voiture et puis lors de la semaine de
la mobilité en fait ce qui est
particulier dans les pays eux c'est que
là on vient sur le terrain c'est toutes
les personnes qui organisent et
déplacement à saint quentin en yvelines
qui n en face des usagers pour discuter
comprendre et entendre les besoins et ce
que nous faisons un focus c'est parce
qu'il ya cette semaine donc il se met
qui se met en place et qui débute demain
à saint quentin en yvelines y
participent il y aura des animations
notamment dans les entreprises dès
demain
dès demain on est au technocentre de
renault par exemple pour échanger avec
les salariés en direct avec les
transporteurs pour parler aussi de
covoiturage de vélo de l'ensemble des
modes de transport ce sont les
entreprises qui ont souhaité être
associés vous les avez des marchés parce
que là vous avez évoqué le technocentre
n'ya pas que le technocentre non je ne
l'exemple du technocentre c'est la
première opération pour lancer la
semaine de la mobilité on va aussi au
crédit agricole on va chez orange on
voit dans différentes entreprises qui
nous ont sollicités qui ont sollicité
notre présente pour cette semaine de la
mobilité alors là on parle des
entreprises les particuliers aussi
peuvent s'y intéresser et j'aimerais
qu'on s'arrête sur ce test de vélos à
assistance électrique par exemple ce
sera mercredi alors par exemple mercredi
on peut essayer des vélos à assistance
électrique on a une animation spécifique
à la ferme du manet la semaine prochaine
voilà la semaine prochaine en fin
d'après midi qui permettra de tester des
vélos avec des vendeurs de vélos qui
sont implantés localement sur le
territoire ou à proximité pour s'adapter
à tous ces modes de déplacements qui
sont valorisés pendant sept semaines
j'imagine aussi que l'agglomération
réfléchi sur l'aménagement des pistes
cyclables par exemple sur des choses
comme ça on réfléchit on écoute beaucoup
surtout et ben justement à l'occasion de
la semaine de la mobilité on lance une
grande enquête sur le réseau de bus
parce qu'en fait on vienne ans un
travail avec un bureau d'études pour
réorganisés restructurer le réseau de
bus pour qu'il soit un peu plus
attractif et plus de lignes sur des
différences tout cas des lônes qui
décerne mieux les habitants donc mieux
entendre leurs besoins donc c'est une
enquête qui sera en ligne à partir de
demain qui se trouve sur le site
internet de l'agglomération et qui
permet de s'exprimer sur l'ensemble du
réseau le réseau actuel ce qui va ce qui
ne va pas et le réseau de demain ce qui
est important pour soi en tant
qu'usagers ce qu'on attend du réseau de
bus et puisqu'on parle de ce réseau de
bus est aussi un travail qui a été mené
avec ski bus il y aura le lancement dans
le cadre de cette semaine de ce système
d'information voyageurs on en avait déjà
parlé l'an dernier sur cette antenne
lorsque c'était encore en train de se
mettre en place là ce sera
officiellement lancée il est honni sera
opérationnel pour la fin du mois de
septembre comment ça fonctionne alors ça
permet un système en gros c'est des
systèmes gps qui permet de suivre le
parc de bus donc qui aide à
l'exploitation l'opérateur de transport
ski bus mais en fait qui permet aux
usagers très concrètement d'avoir dans
les arrêts de bus un temps d'attentes
réels affichés qui permet de savoir si
on n'attend pas le prochain si on change
de trajectoire on croit aussi chasser
les bus oui alors ça c'est la nouveauté
pour cette année c'est il ya eu un
changement d'identité de l'agglomération
et on a un nouveau logo et pour
accompagner ce changement en fait les
les bus change et donc à partir de
demain il ya un premier bus qui sort
avec la nouvelle livrée et donc le
valais dans un jeu donc l'idée c'est que
les usagers la première personne qui
voit le bus le photographier les mettre
sur les réseaux sociaux est bon alors
pour les gens qui aiment le bus ça
permettra de gagner un petit
reproduction des nouvelles livrées de
bus dont qui sont encore en circuit qui
le seront qu'à partir de demain au lieu
de chasser les pokémon faut chasser les
bus à saint quentin en yvelines voilà
c'est le jeu de la rentrée une dernière
question parler du des entreprises et
est justement de cette problématique
d'adapter les déplacements aux besoins
des entreprises et des salariés ça
marche aussi avec l'université par
exemple s'il ya des échanges sur ces
questions là entre l'université
l'agglomération sur les questions de
mobilité oui alors il ya déjà eu des
échanges avec l'université c'est vrai
que c'est un public on connaît par un
par d'autres enquêtes en fait les
yeux c'est parce que en général
70% des salariés n'habitent pas sur le
territoire donc on a eu besoin de mettre
en place ces démarches pour entendre
leurs besoins sur l'université on a eu
accès à un moment donné à des enquêtes
qui ne peut être comprendre les besoins
parce que des résidences universitaires
qui se sont ouvertes un peu partout sur
saint-quentin elles sont pas forcément à
proximité des sites d'enseignement qu'il
faut aussi que les étudiants puissent se
déplacer
allez-y oui oui à réagir sur sa voie et
c'est nouveau c'est une vraie question
pour pour l'université à double titre
c'est à dire notamment la circulation
entre les différents campus sur
l'ensemble du département ce que nos
campus sur les sites sur saint quentin
en yvelines sur versailles sur os montes
sur vélizy qui a une vraie question de
circulation des étudiants et puis il ya
aussi une vraie question sur lequel on
commence à se pencher sans forcément de
concrétisation c'est la possibilité pour
nos étudiants de circuler justement pour
aller dans la zone paris saclay pour
aller sur plateau et ça c'est une
question particulièrement importante
pour nos étudiants pour nos enseignants
chercheurs et pour l'université et sa
force dans le cadre de paris-saclay les
axes de travail qui sont lancés ici sur
ce plateau cette méthode est revenue
pour 7 8 invités qui va se refermer
rendez vous chaque soir est donc ce sera
demain jeudi pour la nouvelle édition
invités notamment philippe yvan c'est le
président du directoire de la société du
grand paris et cette société en charge
de la réalisation du super métro autour
de la capitale on parlera encore de
transports l'information locale se
poursuit sur notre antenne
[Musique]